hey guys this is Jared one of the
creators here at wisecrack today we're
talking about one of the best shows on
TV right now and a personal favorite
Rick and Morty
we know you're probably jonesing for
some new episodes after the year and a
half wait was announced turn into Rick
and Morty season 3 in like a year and a
half so we wanted to hold you over with
an analysis of Rick and Morty so far the
philosophy the science and everything
you missed while you were laughing at
the dick jokes
Rick and Morty chronicles the exploits
of a mad scientist and his naive
grandson as they go on deeply
irresponsible and awesome space
adventures it's more or less the plot of
Back to the Future but doc is a gassy
alcoholic I agree Morty get Marty or
Morty never tries to hit on his mom and
the duo travels through alternate
dimensions rather than time Rick and
Morty is deeply rooted in the traditions
of sci-fi horror often paying homage to
things like Ghostbusters filmmaker David
Cronenberg Oh in Marty I really
Cronenberg the world up tonight
Nosferatu and Freddy Krueger to name a
few the show even references Zardoz a
camp classic and guilty pleasure of mine
nowhere else where you get to see Sean
Connery in a futuristic space song but
seriously you see the movie it's
actually really smart while the show
pays homage to a wide spectrum of sci-fi
and horror it has an affinity for a
particular sci-fi tradition cosmic
horror pioneered by literary horror
legend HP Lovecraft the cosmic horror
genre emphasizes the terror of that
which is outside our grasp to comprehend
like Lovecraft Rick and Morty uses the
cosmos as a way to explore deep
philosophical questions by imagining
what lies hidden in the black depths of
space the show opening even makes a
visual reference to Lovecraft's Cthulhu
cosmic horror goes way beyond just cheap
jump scares it presents us with the vast
unknown and unimaginable that
simultaneous feeling of fright disgust
in dread that we feel as whatever lurks
in incomprehensible space suddenly comes
crashing into our own reality Rick's
portal gun is constantly confronting us
with this unknown as he jumps headfirst
into other realities the results are
sometimes horrifying sometimes hilarious
sometimes both occasionally that reality
comes to us particularly in the episode
get schwifty
earth is approached by a giant space
head whose sheer gravitational mass
causes mayhem on earth's ecosystem the
giant head commands the entirety of
earth to show him what they've got
a cult soon develops to worship this
cosmic entity and Rick realizing the
head is a chrome Yulin informs the
president that they have to come up with
a hit song and when the intergalactic
equivalent of America's Got Talent
or be disintegrated by a giant space
laser giant floating cosmic entities
aren't anything new in the science
fiction universe our old friend HP
Lovecraft used the idea constantly
developing a race of great old ones who
he describes in books like Call of
Cthulhu and the Dunwich horror there are
a few interesting questions that big
floating scary things bring up first
cosmic horror begs the question are we
significant most science fiction is
convinced that humanity is
metaphorically the center of the
universe whether we're battling the
Empire or trying to get all the aliens
to just be friends
humanity or things that look like
humanity takes center stage cosmic or
invert that premise and asks the
question what if the universe doesn't
give a [ __ ] about us
for the Kremlin's humanity is merely an
object of entertainment annihilating a
planet is not an act of spite or a cause
for concern it's just something you do
cosmic horror is full of these giant
entities that demonstrate just how
insignificant humanity actually is and
that's what is really terrifying or in
the case of Rick and Morty kind of
hilarious in a dark dark way in the book
in the dust of this planet contemporary
American philosopher Eugene Thacker
describes this cosmic pessimism
prevalent in the horror genre that
imagines a world without us and thinks
through the universe as absolutely
unhuman and indifferent to the hopes
desires and struggles of human
individuals and groups the show embodies
this cosmic pessimism almost perfectly
Rick and Morty even die only to be
replaced by one of the infinite other
versions of themselves in an alternate
reality not only are we but a speck of
dust on a tiny blue marble in the cosmos
at large were also like one of an
infinite amount of the exact same speck
of dust there's an infinite number
realities Morty Rick and Morty doesn't
want us to be terrified of our own
insignificance it wants us to laugh at
it even though we are but specks of dust
Stu these cosmic horrors we too are the
cosmic horrors to other specks of dust
in the Rick's must be crazy we learned
that Rick's car battery is powered by a
micro universe whose sole purpose is to
perform an inane task produce energy and
in that universe they invent another
mini universe and so on and so on Rick
might as well be one of Lovecraft's
cosmic deities to the denizens of the
micro verses it's like cosmic inception
brah it's like Inception Morty in a
multiverse beyond our comprehension with
infinite possibilities values and
meanings start to slip away what about
the reality where Hitler cured cancer
Morty the answer is don't think about it
all that can remain is pessimism which
brings us to our next section on the
existentialism of Rick and Morty Rick
and Morty addresses the question of our
very existence in almost every single
episode nobody exists on purpose nobody
belongs anywhere everybody's gonna die
on the one hand we have the cosmic
insignificance of humanity as a whole
and on the other we have the frivolity
of individual human life that's my grave
the show offers us two examples of how
to respond to our pathetic existence
through Rick and Jerry first we have
Jerry who is seemingly oblivious to the
soul-crushing mediocrity and
pointlessness of his own life he is
literally more happy in a poor
simulation of the world than his actual
life I am
finally complete or as arthur
schopenhauer might well have described
jerry's life the life of every
individual viewed as a whole and in
general and when only its most
significant features are emphasized is
really a tragedy but gone through in
detail it has the character of a comedy
jerry is a failure he's unemployed his
wife hates him and he's not exactly the
sharpest tool in the shed
but one can argue that jerry is better
off than the belligerently drunk rick
because he's simply too dumb to realize
that his life is pointless
but in this ignorance jerry seems
content toiling away for the sake of
nothing life is effort and I'll stop
when I die then there's Rick who
understands the meaninglessness of life
and accepts it
but despite Rick's sarcasm and
nonchalant attitude towards pain and
suffering he's also an alcoholic whose
catchphrase means I'm in great pain do
you know what Wubba lubba dub dub means
it means I am in great pain please help
me the pure rationalism of the universe
furthers the feeling of insignificance
of our own lives we're left with the
paradox science allows us to make some
sort of sense of the universe through
formulas and theorems but we as humans
are left confronting the bleak arbitrary
nature of our own existence yes I'd like
to order one large sofa chair with extra
chair please high chair no recliner
science can reason away any sense of
sanctity or emotion and turn the human
experience into something meaningless
Rick takes time out of avoiding his own
pending death to explain mathematically
that summer and Morty are both pieces of
[ __ ] Rick goes on to rationalize away
his feelings for Morty explaining that
their bond is only an easy way to hide
Rick's genius brainwaves
you're as dumb as I am smart from the
intergalactic Popo in another episode
morty as roy grows up and dies in a
video game after losing he briefly
forgets his own existence where's my you
were just playing a game the audience is
left to question what exactly separates
the fake reality of the roy game to his
own existence after all if Morty
remembers his fake life and experiences
all the emotions and sensations that
constitute our own consciousness what's
the difference Rick and Morty is
constantly playing with this dichotomy
between meaningless simulations
and our actual life really crap if we
recoil from the idea of living a fake
life inside a video game it's because we
ascribe some meaning to the authenticity
of our own waking life but Rick and
Morty is quick to display for all that
that is a giant crock of [ __ ] no what's
the difference between killing the
memory parasites whom the family feels
genuine emotion for and shooting say mr.
poopy butthole this crisis of values of
our own meaning in life is taken up by
tons of existentialists but our old
friend Friedrich Nietzsche is
particularly helpful here Nietzsche
tells the parable of the madman who
comes into town screaming God is dead
and we have killed him now what
Nietzsche was really trying to say is
that after the Enlightenment and the
Scientific Revolution the big being in
the sky that gave value to our lives was
no longer relevant after the death of
God and philosophy what remains is
nihilism a void of meaning this struggle
over the lack of meaning is what defines
Rick Sanchez Rick uses science to
demystify everything does evil exist and
if so can one detect and measure it Oh
rhetorical question Morty the answer is
yes you just have to be a genius love is
just a set of chemical reactions what
people call love is just a chemical
reaction that compels animals to breed
even beats the devil and in a way
actively plays out the death of God yes
we're constantly left wondering what
does Rick care about if anything at all
Rick's character embodies a tension
between a kind of active and passive
nihilism the passive nihilists for
Nietzsche is resigned to the
hopelessness and meaninglessness of life
the active nihilist however actively
seeks to destroy the old values and
start anew well scientifically
traditions are an idiot thing it's clear
that something makes Rick tick we're
just not sure what after all he's
labeled as an intergalactic terrorist
fighting for something and eventually he
gives himself up to save his family
Rick's actions may seem paradoxical if
only because he himself is struggling to
make meaning out of the universe
the show also does its part to
interrogate our own sense of morality
refusing to draw clear lines between
right and wrong or good and evil I will
kill anyone anywhere
I just loved killin Morty's attempts to
be a do-gooder are always Thorton after
freeing a group of people from the
body-snatching unity a nipple driven
race war commences between the now freed
rabble of pedophiles and prostitutes
when confronted with the grim
consequences some are aptly replies I
didn't know freedom meant people doing
stuff that sucks herein lies another
existential question what is biological
life without living listen unity I don't
think my sister's trying to say that
life would be perfect without you I
think she's just saying that life would
be you know life if we the audience are
repulsed by the thought of Body
Snatchers
the show also makes us consider the fact
that our irrational attachment to
freedom is what allows us to live in a
world that is oh so terribly [ __ ] up
another way to look at the existential
question in Rick and Morty is through
the work of Albert Camus specifically in
meeseeks and destroy' the central tenant
of Camus absurdism is that life consists
of two irreconcilable facets the human
tendency to find meaning in life and the
universe's complete indifference to our
existence in Rick and Morty we see the
opposite of this in the meeseeks for
Camus human life was exactly the
opposite as illustrated in the myth of
Sisyphus the king who was sentenced to
spend an eternity pushing a boulder up a
hill only for it to fall back down upon
completion over and over again or for
Jerry it's not a boulder but his golf
swing and then there's this earth rick
c-137 the council of ricks sentences you
to the machine of unspeakable dude which
swaps your conscious and unconscious
mind rendering your fantasies pointless
while everything you've known becomes
impossible to grasp many characters in
the show rather than seek meaning for
their own existence
simply resent their creators for
bringing him into this world I didn't
ask you before we see this Frankenstein
complex not only in the meeseeks
but a neighbor Dolph Winkler you brought
me into this world a suffering
abomination tortured by the duality of
its being but I shall finally know peace
when I watch The Life Drain from Morty
jr. and of course Frankenstein's monster
himself makes an appearance for Camus we
are perpetually frustrated by our
floundering attempt to find meaning and
purpose in life and our inability to do
so he offers as an alternative to
embrace the emptiness of the absurd or
as rick says the answer is don't think
about it or to quote Morty nobody exists
on purpose nobody belongs anywhere
everybody's gonna die come watch TV the
fictional and sometimes almost real
science of Rick and Morty allows us to
explore all the ways that despite our
love for Rick our lives are a sad and
pathetic is Jerry's Oh Jerry but the
science in the show also works as an
excuse for some really nerdy jokes our
times gonna need a little time to you
know stabilize some are obvious like the
entire episode loosely based off the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle this
principle from quantum mechanics
pioneered by a notable meth dealer
states that it is impossible to know
both the location and momentum of a
particle that's because the tiny objects
that make up our universe are at the
same time waves and particles if that's
confusing it's because it is Rick and
Morty draws humor from a superficial
reading of science here claiming that
this uncertainty of quantum mechanics
can cause our own realities to split
outside a sea of Schrodinger's cats are
floating around a reference to the 1935
thought experiment by Irvin Schrodinger
it Ponder's in a quantum world where
particles can be two things at once is
it possible for a cat rigged with an
elaborate quantum booby trap to be both
alive and dead at the same time because
Austrians have dark dark imaginations
this tenuous relationship to scientific
truth could be viewed as a jab at the
science fiction genre for constantly
inventing scientific mumbo-jumbo to
justify unlikely plot points that is
lorian's our microscopic life-form that
resides
it sounds like stupid and smart brain
waves cancelling each other out in
another episode rick is seen traversing
tiny climates on a tiny planet which is
not at all how that works in the same
episode the show's creators poked fun at
the trust we place in TV narratives by
making a joke about forced perspective I
thought it was further away the show
also exhibits a unique kind of atheism
that constantly invalidates religious
figures by boiling them down to pure
science all previous existing religions
I'm going out onto the sidewalk I'm
dropping to my knees and pledging my
eternal soul to the thing that literally
controls the inn whether it also
acknowledges the frequent misuse of
science by those with religious agendas
you can't kill the true father in
something Rickett this way comes Jerry's
personal interpretation of science leads
him on a crusade to reinstate Pluto's
planet hood he is greeted by the
Plutonians who have not-so-subtle
crosses in their eyes drawing a
comparison to religious fundamentalism
of course it's all a ploy to manipulate
Plutonians into thinking the destruction
of their planet by their corporate
overlords is totally not a big deal hmm
so to pull it all together Rick and
Morty is a show that holds nothing as
sacred by exploring the absurdities of a
purely rational universe and pushing the
boundaries of decency in a sci-fi horror
setting we get to ask all sorts of fun
depressing questions like why am I here
and what's the point of it all we're not
really sure where the show will go with
Rick's character will he finally do
something for the greater good or is his
latest move just another bleak
self-serving ploy as always thanks for
watching
what would love a dub dub we hope you're
liking these special episodes we have
some amazing new videos around the
corner on the South Park movie
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and
lots more be sure to check out our
channel page by clicking here where you
can see more of our brain tickling
videos while you're over there do be
sure to hit the subscribe button another
great way to support the show is by
supporting our sponsors this episode is
sponsored by audible.com audible is the
world's leading source of digital
audiobooks they've got more than 180,000
downloadable titles across all types of
literature including bestsellers latest
releases and classics and if you're
looking for a book recommendation that's
wacky and fun like Rick and Morty and
want to be already when our video hits
check out Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy by Douglas Adams for more about
audible and to start your 30-day free
trial go to audible.com slash 8bit to
sign up thanks for the support and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]